来吧,好的,聊聊这个话题吧
这个信号不太好,我在高体上
我上次就拍一条视频,传了一碗,被传上去
可能也会被打断,什么呢,正常就要
什么就要没困难创造困难吗,对吧
其他这个话题的要,就是我昨天的提到,我们大部分人
它其实是在一个老鼠商里
老鼠商里,它是没有级类的
一直上学上了学买了方
参加工作,然后每天重复同样的工作
没有记得,一旦这个行业下滑,一旦公司结体
对吧
亚当思密与说过那个话
它说什么,说一旦一个人,它长期重视一些
简单重复的操作,那这个人就费了
别下大了,就发明了这个体系的人,它居然
点出了这个问题,那怎么办呢,怎么办呢
我昨天发完了以后,然后就人就提出这个
也要说终于发现这个问题,结果还好的人回忆父,在下面留言说
这个都知道,但是
不知道选什么,不知道该干什么,对吧
它其实是我们的另外几个选庆,什么先进呢
首先我们说第一个叫
销生客选庆,大家看过那个电脑吧,对吧,就是
你在建议里待身长了,你越遇到你出了以后你不知道干啥
就你知道问题做在,你解决不了
一个很装的原因是什么,就是我们的
我们的信息是封闭的,封闭到什么程度呢
就是你想你的认知是不够的,你想去解决你想跳出来
身边的人没有任何人可以给你建议,对吧
这就是我一直说的是如果我们是普通家庭的还得出身
真的是如果你是窮人家还得出身
你要做的第一件事情,不是转钱,是改变你的思维认知
你的思维认知不变,你所有的行为
其实很多说的入校的,就是你在错的路上不断的,不断的跳
对吧,有的互联网以后又在每个好处了,就是你能看到外面的世界,但是很多人放弃了
很多人放弃了呀,就是你看到东西都是信息兼房的
对吧,你看到信息都是你想看到的,我没有主动出去看信息,以后我可以告大家去对的方法
我们大部分那个嘛
就是马上又是另外一个陷阱了,什么陷阱呢,耐头落陷阱
耐头落陷阱,人人耐头落陷阱了
你看我辛苦的这么长,我坐在靠到靠到自己吧,我累得这么时间
对吧,每次打个游戏,看个段视频,对吧,看个小说啊,对吧
然后,然后你的时间就被消不过了
然后当你发现问你的时候,你要去坐点,什么事说,你没有,你没什么事可坐
你也不知道该看什么事
于是干嘛呢,就又变成另外一个叫灵宫效应效应
这个陷阱
这个你只能打两个灵宫,怎么办呀,什么呢,就这种大家随时能想到的东西
于是你就会
在一个农次的陷阱里面跳出一个陷阱,有另外一个陷阱等着你
对吧,然后就是刚才我说的,你看那个老伙估计不说嘛,就是我知道怎么回事,我不知道该怎么学
所以这说怎么办呢
我给大家建议要几个方法,但是我说了,其实你们也
打不认你做不到
但是我还是说吧
首先,第一季你确实请你要起掉耐耐头,你老含耐怎么醒啊
对吧
所以其实
你看我
我不是推销东西
我我刚才还哥
和我同时,跑要聊天,我说我现在用这种
这种越度起,这种越度起,这种越度起,原本的原因是什么呢,是因为它只有黑白的都演一号
但是后来我发现它一个最大的好处是什么,它没有实上头
它那个没有娱乐的东西
你就说你说我看个视频,看不了,打开游戏吧,这还怎么能怎么打游戏呀
也没个道相机,它只能越度,哇太好了
所以我说最好的身上的一共就有什么的,是非性模式
所以有一些时候,就是你要借掉一些东西
就是
借掉那个奶头
用这个时间干嘛
我看不到,我不知道我要做什么,那怎么办
会在我的视野嘛
所以第二步的话呢
就是你要看世界
兄弟们,真的是看世界啊,什么叫看世界啊
一广看你们村的东西
那不行呢,对吧,你一广看你们好那东西不行了
一广看美女跳舞,这个不行呢
你真的是看世界,什么是看世界
就是我们要知道这个世界是怎么运转的
非洲、亚洲、欧洲、美洲,这传织世界,你得去看
你的视野了,到那,第二你要知道这个世界是怎么运转的
多少了点,你了解点
经济学技术,了解一些历史了,对吧,这个
都是怎么起来的,到钱是怎么来的,他怎么
他怎么能够持续的,要商业模式,你大概是能看动的,对吧
然后,按你是到这个钱为什么,他能中钱
对吧,为什么
他能卖出去,对吧
他为什么可以市场
可以做的怎么大
然后我没有了解一些概率思维,就很多时候真的是概率的
真的是概率,如果有能力,我就能成功,不是有概率的
对不对
那么这个东西有没有用,看世界有没有用,有用吗,我看今天还有一个人在下面留言
说这个每天写点,什么整个生钱,很简单呀,刚才我说了,你看世界
一把你看个世界紧拆结出来
对吧,我今天看一个什么世界,我发现AI
改变世界吗,对吧,AI有出什么东西,他运量了什么机会
对吧,然后漂亮有出现一个什么样的政策,有什么样的新闻
这个对我们有什么样的机会
对不对,然后通过底层国际,你去分析他
每天写点什么
那就有种看啊
一边学习一边对外说说,就说每天说的这个东西啊
对吧
然后第三个部分的话,就是我刚才说的
概率,就做一件事情都是概率的
因为我能力能力高,你概率可能会高一点,对吧,就是你的成功的原因,你的
命中于成理出手的次数成育概率吗,对不对
所以我看很多人的最大的问题,什么呢,还怕失败
哎呀,我怕翻桌
我错了怎么办
错了就错了嘛,那有什么嘛
只要成本
不是那么高
对吧,然后你去动手动手了以后,你就发现哦,原来是这个样子
你就会总结一些经历
我给我给你每个公事啊,特别好玩
就是什么呢,叫做你的痛苦成育可负质
就是你发现这个痛苦,它是可以被负质的
原来有给被负质,那其实全是手艺啊
所以其实你看到这个世界以后,你发现了一个机会之后,你就最少的成本去失错
不要紧,你错了也好,你对了也好错了以后,你把他写出来,这叫闭兰
对吧,然后你正确以后,你会告诉我哦,这叫公务
错了以后,又正确的那个更棒,对吧,其实就是痛点,然后解决访
只要遇到的问题,别插不动,你只要做这个事情,别人都能遇到吧,这个东西是不是也可以写出来呢
所以其实就是,这都是非常非常简单的方法
但是我说了以后,大部分是不愿意动的
大部分都是说,你直接告诉我结果,你还给我讲这么一大堆东西有什么用呢
这恰恰就是我们的机会所在